Bonjour Eric Zemmour. Vous revenez
aujourd'hui sur l'initiative présidentielle de
lancer un référendum sur le climat, c'est bien jouénon ?
Je pense que c'est la première réaction de tous, c'est bien joué, voussavez en France on n'est pas seulement citoyen
on est aussi un peu "afficionado". On regarde la
politique avec les yeux du football
d'amateurs de corridas et on dit "ça c'est bien joué,
c'est une belle passe, c'est un beau dribble etc".
Bon très bien, on se souvient des référendums passés
de celui de Chirac sur le quinquennat,
même pour les plus anciens se souviennent de
Pompidou sur l'entrée de la Grande-Bretagne dans
l'Europe en 72 qui avait divisé l'union de la
gauche qui à l'époque menaçait son pouvoir.
D'accord, tactiquement, c'est bien joué on
dit chapeau etc. Maintenant, derrière,
on s'interroge, forcément. Déjà, est ce qu'on a
besoin encore de réformer la Constitution ?
On a déjà transformé les lois en espèces de textes
bavards qui sont des des pétitions de principe etc.
Est ce qu'on a besoin que la Constitution
devienne ça aussi. Mais l'urgence climatique
ne justifie pas un référendum selon vous ?
C'est la question suivante. D'abord pourquoi
transformer encore la Constitution ? Première
question. On en a déjà trop fait, on l'a déjà
trop modifié. On a modifié l'équilibre admirable de
la Constitution écrite par Debré et part
De Gaulle. Deuxièmement, alors là votre question,
est ce que le climat nécessite un référendum?
Est ce que c'est une question assez importante ?
Apparemment c'est une question très importante.
Mais est ce que ça nous concerne seulement nous
français ? Est ce que c'est une
question que peut régler le peuple français ? Je
suis pas sûr. En plus est ce que
c'est la question vraiment urgente aujourd'hui ?
Alors que nous avons une crise sanitaire dont
on n'arrive pas à se sortir. Nous avons une crise
sanitaire qui va provoquer une crise économique
et sociale énorme et que nous avons des jihadistes
qui tuent régulièrement, ponctuellement partout en
France, que nous avons une immigration que nous
maîtrisons plus qui est devenue depuis longtemps
une "invasion" selon le mot du président
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing qui vient de mourir et
que nous avons des "quartiers islamisés qui
se détachent petit à petit de la République
Française" selon la fameuse formule de Macron
lui même sur le séparatisme. Il y a des sujets
qu'on pourrait traiter par référendum. Je suis pas sûr
que le climat soit un sujet qu'on pourrait traiter
par référendum, dire que oui il faut protéger
le climat mais encore. Pour vous choisir
le thème du climat comme sujet de référendum ce
n'est pas anodin ? Oui, c'est à dire que l'on voit
bien au delà de la tactique : désarmer les
verts qui seront obligés de les suivre embêter
le Sénat qui sera obligé d'acquiescer sous peine
de passer pour un ennemi du climat. Bonvoyez
le coup tactique qu'on a apprécié au début.
Mais il y a une sociologie qui est révélatrice.
On a vu lors des dernières municipales,
les verts ont fait une percée uniquement dans
les métropoles. C'est à dire il y a une certaine
sociologie, les gens qui habitent les métropoles.
Les vainqueurs de la mondialisation, ce qu'on
caricature sous le terme de "bobo", c'est eux qui
se soucient du climat, c'est eux qui votent vert,
c'est eux qui veulent des villes avec des vélosetc.
La france périphérique selon la terminologie
de Christophe Guilluy, elle, ce n'est pas son sujet,
ce n'est pas le sujet principal. Si vous voulez
il ya deux France y a la France des métropoles
qui se soucient du climat qui craint le grand
réchauffement et il y a la France périphérique
qui se soucie de social et d'immigration qui craint
le grand déclassement et le grand remplacement et
entre ces deux France, c'était déjà le clivage de
2017 et il va se coaliser, se coaguler autour de
cette question référendaire. Je ne suis pas sûr
contrairement à la présidentielle où il y avait
la présence commode de Marine Le Pen voyez
pour permettre à Macron d'être largement
majoritaire, là il n'y a pas la présence de
Marine Le Pen et donc on a les deux France
et Christophe Guilluy nous a appris que c'était
la France périphérique qui était majoritaire, ce
n'est pas la France d'Emmanuel Macron. Donc là ça
peut être très intéressant d'ailleurs, on va enfin
coaliser c'est deux France. Si les gens vont voter,
parce que il y aura le problème de l'abstention,
mais si les gens vont voter on aura enfin c'est deux
France qui vont se révéler et s'affirmer l'une en
face de l'autre et là on verra effectivement
parce qu'un référendum ça se gagne quand la
question est essentielle. Les institutions en 58 et en 62
l'Algérie en 61, l’Europe en 92,
même si c'était de justesse mais ça se gagne. Mais
ça se perd aussi, Chirac l'a perdu en 2005
sur l'Europe, De Gaulle a perdu en 1969 sur les
régions parce que personne ne comprenait quel
était l'importance de la suppression du Sénat.
Donc Emmanuel macron prend son risque, il risque
de tomber dans ce que Francois Mauriac appelé la
maladresse des demis-habile. Merci Eric Zemmour.